ECONOMY: Hi. If everyone could take this time
to please check their cell phones and turn
them off, please, so we have no disruption
to our discussion. I wanted to announce this
meeting will be on the record, and it is being
streamed live on CFR.org and on CFR's YouTube
channel. Enjoy the discussion. Thank you.
HAASS: OK. If people could please leave some
hors d'oeuvres for afterwards and we can -- we
can get going here.
Seriously, people, we've got quite a few seats
here up front.
I see 10 over here.
OK. Good evening. I'm Richard Haass and I
want to personally welcome everybody here
to the Council on Foreign Relations tonight.
Tonight we are here to celebrate, to recognize
and, ultimately, to buy and read.
ECONOMY: Especially buy.
HAASS: Especially buy, yes. Forced to choose
between buying and reading, we know where
the authors come out.
(LAUGHTER)
The title of the book, By All Means Necessary;
the subtitle of the book, How China's Resource
Quest is Changing the World. The authors of
the book, Liz Economy, who is the C.V. Starr
senior fellow and director for Asia Studies
here at the Council on Foreign Relations.
And her co-author is Michael Levi. And Michael's
the David M. Rubenstein senior fellow for
Energy and the Environment, and directs the
program at the Council on energy security
and climate change. And they are the coauthors
of this new, important and readable book.
So let's begin, as they sang in that movie,
at the very beginning. Why this title? Why
-- What does 'By All Means Necessary' refer
to, Liz?
ECONOMY: OK. Before I get into that, let me
just have my Oscar moment and thank you, Richard...
(LAUGHTER)
... for providing...
HAASS: You want to say how everybody loves
you?
ECONOMY: OK.
HAASS: You can have your Shirley McLaine moment
too.
ECONOMY: I thought it was Sally Field, but
anyway.
HAASS: Sally Field, whatever. Sorry about
that.
ECONOMY: That's OK. No, but thank you, Richard,
first off for providing such a terrific environment
in which Mike and I could write the book,
and such patience as well too for us to give
birth to this book.
And also I think we want to thank our scores
of research associates and interns who provided
us with enormous assistance and, in particular,
our two current research associates, Will
Piekos and Alex Mahler-Haug. And I think I
want to thank our fifth floor friends as well
because they really sustain us through all
of this.
HAASS: Just to be clear, fifth floor is their
colleagues, not the mice.
ECONOMY: Yes. OK. So those are my thanks.
You may have your own thanks to make as well.
Why don't I take the -- I'll take the title
then. And maybe you want to take the subtitle,
because they really reflect two different
parts of the book and I think two different
things that we're trying to get at.
The title really is a reflection of all of
the tools that China has at its disposal to
secure resources from outside its boundaries.
So this can be everything from, you know,
Xi Jinping's personal diplomacy to sort of
vast trade, aid and investment deals that
we see China attempting to strike when it
goes to resource-rich countries.
To the low-cost financing and labor that Chinese
firms can bring to the table, often times
seeming to undercut Western multinationals.
To other kinds of things like corruption and
back door deals that can get struck between
some leaders of resource-rich countries and
their Chinese counterparts.
It can also mean things like a willingness
to put down stakes, money-losing stakes for
long periods of time with the hope that a
deal will pay off down the line. So the Chinese
have a long time horizon in many instances.
HAASS: Can I ask (inaudible).
ECONOMY: Yes, OK.
HAASS: The risk of getting into the substance.
When you say so the Chinese are willing to
put down stakes and even take a loss for quite
some time in the hope -- and I think your
words were "the deal will pay off." What does
pay off mean?
How does -- how do the Chines measure the
value or -- is it by economic? Is it strategic?
Is it something else? What's their yardstick?
ECONOMY: That's an excellent question.
Actually, it depends on who you're talking
about. You know, for the Chinese government
it can mean the strategic sort of element.
So for example, some of you may have just
seen -- I think it was in the Financial Times
there was an article talking about the National
Development Reform Commission telling the
Chinese steel producers that they should continue
to go out and take stakes in iron-ore production,
right.
But Chinese steel producers have no interest
in that. They have overcapacity. They don't
want to do that. But the NDRC came out and
said well listen, this is important for strategic
reasons, and because we want to have a say
in global trade. It's important for our voice
in the global trading arena.
So that's an example of where there's a difference
between the interest of the companies to make
money and the interest of the government to
kind of have a big political voice.
HAASS: And I assume when there's a slight
difference of interest it's not always the
company that wins?
ECONOMY: No, but it's surprisingly sometimes
the companies have some passive aggressive
ways of dealing with it.
HAASS: Michael, before we get much further.
Talk about the subtitle, which is 'How China's
Resource Quest is Changing the World.' Is
it changing the world, and if so, how and
how much?
LEVI: So, first, I want to echo Liz's thanks
to everyone. I won't repeat all of them, but
thank you all to everyone.
HAASS: You can thank me if you'd like.
LEVI: Particularly Richard for creating such
a fantastic environment.
So we picked the subtitle mostly for search
engine optimization.
ECONOMY: Oh my God. I didn't even know what
that meant.
(LAUGHTER)
This is what I get for having Mike as my coauthor.
LEVI: But secondarily we couldn't call it
"Why China's -- China Resource Quest was Changing
the World." We're focused on identifying the
different places where China is changing the
world, but also the places where it isn't.
So this is not a book about how China's resource
quest is changing everything in the world,
but about seeing what's real and really what's
myth out there. And I'm not going to list
all the different ways in which it's changing
the world, but maybe I'll highlight two or
three.
There's enormous focus on Chinese investment
in countries. But where the biggest economic
consequences have come so far is actually
from Chinese trade. Chinese demand for minerals,
for energy, for food have helped drive up
prices, with huge consequences for economies
around the world, regardless of whether China
is an investor in those.
So if you want a headline, top way that China's
resource quest is changing the world, resources
are more expensive, people want more of them
and the economic consequences for producers
and for consumers are huge.
Another really interesting place where China
is changing the world is in its efforts to
make sure that there are secure routes for
those resources to get back to China. And
we tend to take this integrated nature of
the global economy for granted that something
produced in one part of the world can be moved
to another very quickly.
I don't know that the Chinese do, particularly
when they look at their backyard, at the sea
lanes near them, congested, contested by a
lot of different countries, for a variety
of different reasons, not just because of
resource trade. But increasingly I think you
see China paying attention and asserting its
interests in that region. And we'll see increasing
security consequences from that.
HAASS: There's an urban, I don't know if it's
legend or myth or assumption surrounding the
subject. And the only reason I know it because
I'm an expert on neither China nor Africa.
Is every time -- many times when I speak publicly
about foreign policy and international relations
I get asked the question along the following
lines, which says, shouldn't we be worried
about what China is doing in Africa? Aren't
they cornering the market for some purpose,
be it financial, strategic or both? And aren't
we going to wake up one day and regret it?
What is your sense -- is this, if you will,
an urban or nonurban myth? Or is there actually
something to this? Should we be worried about
China's quest?
ECONOMY: I'll start and maybe, Mike, you want
to pick up. I think, to Mike's first point,
one of the interesting things that we found
was that China really -- its resource quest
primarily rooted in trade rather than investment.
And actually when you look at Chinese investment
in Africa compared to others, it actually
ranks fourth in the world. It's not the largest
investor in Africa, which you know everybody
assumes.
When you look at sort of China's search for
land, you know, it's third, right, after Canada
and the United States, and quite a distant
third. So it's important to keep everything,
you know, relative and keep it in proportion
to what actually is going on.
I think in terms of Africa, certainly it is
exerting a profound impact, you know, in governance
issues. And so whether you're looking at labor
issues or environmental issues, really just
have to look back at what China does on the
home front to understand the impact that it's
having in Africa, as well as other places.
HAASS: But should...
ECONOMY: Should we be concerned?
HAASS: Should we be competing with them more?
Should we basically be talking to African
governments or others to block China to some
extent? Is this something that we will strategically
come to rue?
LEVI: I think it depends on the resource.
And we have to look at the structure of different
resource markets. And that's one of the reasons
we went so broad in the book.
If you look at oil, for example, African oil
is still a limited part of the global market.
The Chinese right now sell most of the oil
they produce in Africa onto the open market.
Could they in a crisis direct that back to
China? Sure. But there would be plenty of
other resource from elsewhere to make up for
the suppliers that tend to buy that.
Now, you can get into other markets where
there's a lot more concentration. And you
want to make sure there's diversity. So if
China were to go and start to buy up a lot
of rare earth deposits in Africa, a place
where they have a lot of concentration and
where there's been a trend toward diversification
that we want to intensify, then that would
be a place where we have a strong strategic
interest and we would want to divert that.
And there's another place where it's important,
and this is rooted in economics but gets into
politics. The Chinese companies can sometimes
make it easy for African governments, Latin
American governments, other governments to
set up regimes for investment that are not
particularly strong.
So there're ones that are appealing to Chinese
companies but don't bring all of the other
capital and technology and capabilities in.
In the long run that means that we have less
resources in the world, higher prices for
consumers, less security for all of us. So
we should be careful to make sure that countries
don't get suckered into doing the easy thing
that hurts us in the long run.
HAASS: Liz, I often hear stories that the
Chinese when they invest in Africa often bring
a lot of their own workforce with them. And
that just like 30, 40 years ago there used
to be the phrase "the ugly American" for some
of what we were doing in Asia and other parts
of what used to be the Third World, I actually
hear stories that now the idea of "the ugly
Chinese" and that in Africa there's lots of
resentment. How true?
ECONOMY: True. Although primarily in the infrastructure
rather than in areas like mining and oil and
gas. But still you do find it. And I think
you find it in a couple of different ways.
So it can be -- and frankly what we're talking
about in terms of Africa applies as well to
Southeast Asia and sometimes to Latin America.
So this is not -- you know Africa's received
sort of the bulk of media attention. But really
what Mike and I did was look across the entire
landscape and find that all these practices
are replicated from one region to the next.
But to your point, yes ugly Chinese. There's
enormous sort of resentment about -- both
in terms of when you have Chinese managers
of mines who believe in some ways as some
foreign ministry officials would say to me
that you know Africans don't work hard, that's
why we need to bring our labor in.
They like to sing and dance. They want to
go to church and have labor unions and all
sorts of inconvenient things, and not work
on the weekends. And so we need to bring in
our own labor, right. They're willing to work
longer hours and for cheaper rates.
There's also a problem when it comes to the
individual Chinese going across. Not just
companies bringing in their management and
then exploiting their labor, but you also
have, for example, in the case of Ghana you
know several villages in Guangdong province
simply up and move to Ghana and begin gold
mining and cause a lot of environmental problems.
So this is not something that's state directed,
and in fact caused enormous problems for the
foreign ministry and the Chinese government.
In the end, the Ghanaian government kicked
them out last summer, kicked out 4,500 Chinese
miners. And in retaliation apparently, the
Chinese have slowed the visa process and are
making it difficult for the Ghanaian government
to access a $3 billion loan.
So there is a huge challenge. Issues of communication,
issues of low pay, issues of no labor safety,
these are all the things that you know mining
workers who work for Chinese mines talk about,
whether you're talking about Africa or Papua
New Guinea or elsewhere.
HAASS: Given some of that, if when we're looking
at this as a historical trajectory is it your
sense that, if you will, the China moment
in Africa has peaked?
ECONOMY: Well, I don't know whether it's peaked.
I think one of the things that Mike and I
try to do in the book is not just look at
this very moment, but try to look a little
bit at what the Chinese are doing to improve
their situation. And so when you're looking
at issues sort of that are tied into corporate
social responsibility, you do find now that
you have change being brought. You know in
part by what's taking place at home, right.
So when you've got the Chinese themselves
demanding better environmental standards from
their companies that will then become what
the Chinese companies export, or better labor
standards. You also have pressure from the
outside. States with stronger capacity demand
that the Chinese do a better job.
And you have learning. I think in some cases,
for example in Peru, we found you know early
entrants in the mining sector had very poor
practices across the board. Much later entrants,
however, began to take advantage of infrastructure
that had developed so that they hired you
know Western consultants, maybe bring in a
local you know mining head. And so you have
a much better evaluation of Chinese practices
now, pretty much 10 to 15 years down the line.
LEVI: Richard, to your question, I don't think
it's peaked rather than the honeymoon is over.
And people have had experience and they don't
like a lot of that experience.
And I think it's intensified, and Liz pointed
to that when she talked about Ghana. It's
intensified as smaller players have been able
to get out there and they're tougher to control.
When I was working on the book I went to Zambia.
Zambia has this notorious mine, column mine.
It's a private Chinese mine. Every few months
someone seems to get shot at it, whether it's
a worker or a Chinese manager.
And I went and visited with the Chinese ambassador
in Lusaka. And I brought up -- I brought up
the mine. I was a bit nervous doing it. It's
a very hot button issue. And he said, "If
you want to buy this mine I will do everything
I can do to have them sell it to you."
(LAUGHTER)
It gives you some sense of how uneven the
Chinese government's control is over what's
happening out there.
HAASS: I want to come back to that question.
I just got a couple more and then we'll open
it up to our members and our guests here tonight.
Which is you know the old saw, whatever you
want to call it, about trade following flag
or flag following the trade.
What's the balance here? What's the engine?
What's the caboose of this interaction with
the world?
ECONOMY: I'm not quite sure. You mean the...
LEVI: So...
ECONOMY: I'm not sure...
LEVI: Is it the companies driving it or is
it the policy driving it? And this is an endless
question.
One thing that came up over and over as we
were researching the book is that the Chinese
government is less capable of directing companies
to do specific things than a lot of people
believe. They can try to put together packages,
but the companies don't necessarily play ball.
The CEOs of the biggest companies have equal
rank to the ministers that are supposed to
govern them. So it makes it tough for one
to win out over the other.
But what the government does do is create
an environment in which it's attractive to
a lot of these companies to go out and do
investments in particular ways. They set up
access to cheap capital. They have a promotion
system, and these leaders are senior party
members.
They are not just looking to make a lot of
money, though that's part of it. They're looking
to get promoted. And promotion means a political
job, a senior political job. And so they're
going to have the state's objectives in the
back of their mind.
But it's a more nuanced interaction. It's
really sort of setting the environment in
the direction rather than dictating the terms
most of the time.
ECONOMY: Let me just...
HAASS: Go ahead.
ECONOMY: Let me just add one thing to just
flesh out what Mike was saying. Which is you
know if you look, the National Development
Reform Commission will list sort of the key
resources that they want companies to go out
and get.
And they will -- the Chinese government will
go out with various ministers, with the heads
of state-owned enterprises to these countries,
and as Mike said you know structure these
big deals. And the NDRC will lay out an entire
plan for a country. But companies don't necessarily
want to participate in those deals.
So sometimes that's what -- when you read,
for example that you know there's $70 billion
promised in resource and infrastructure deals
for Brazil dating back since 2007 and only
30 percent of that has been realized. You
begin to understand that difference between
what the government is saying and what the
firms are actually doing.
HAASS: Your subtitle is How China's Resource
Quest is Changing the World. How is China's
resource quest changing China? What's the
blowback, if you will, from this experience?
ECONOMY: I think it's -- frankly, I think
it's just beginning. I think there are now
a couple of different ways in which the Chinese
public has become quite concerned. For example,
the safety of Chinese citizens, that's something
that the government typically has not paid
much attention to.
And in fact, when about 27 I guess workers
from Sinohydro were kidnapped in Sudan back
in 2012 I want to say, the Chinese government
-- the response form the embassy in Sudan
was well, you're just going to have to expect
this because as we go out more of our workers
are going to go out and this kind of thing
is just going to happen.
And you know the Internet erupted like this
is not acceptable for the Chinese government
to be saying. And things like you know the
U.S. -- if this happened to the United States
you know they would send in the Marines and
all this kind of thing. So what is our government
doing?
And so I think there's a big sort of upsurge
from the general public concerning this issue
of personal safety. And now you have Sinohydro,
for example, developing a list of countries
where they don't want to do business necessarily,
places that they consider dangerous.
And this is something quite new because that
really does fly in the face of we don't mix
business with politics. We don't care what's
going on in the internal situation of a country
-- we're just going there to do business.
But yet the Chinese people and the Chinese
companies are beginning to say well actually
those situations we don't want to do business.
I think the other way in which you're starting
to see things change is people are realizing.
And when you have a change in government like
you have in Burma Myanmar and all of the sudden
the Chinese you know go from being ostensibly
this trusted, most important partner, to the
sort of scourge of the region. They're looking
and saying you know obviously we did something
wrong.
And so now you have Chinese NGOs traveling
to Burma Myanmar and doing investigations
and saying to the Chinese companies you've
clearly mishandled this. You know you've -- you
know all you've done is operate at the top
level. You haven't engaged with the people.
You need to develop better practices.
So these are the kinds of changes that we
see taking place. Nascent I would say, but
this kind of blowback is beginning to affect.
LEVI: Maybe I'll add one small one onto that.
A big consequence of China's resource quest
is that the costs of all these resources have
gone way up. And one of the main reactions
in China is to try and improve efficiency
in order to not have its economy be so exposed
to this extraordinary cost that it, itself
has helped create. And I think it's a huge
piece of China's response.
It's also a big piece that will determine
the future consequences of China's resource
quest. If they succeed in insulating themselves
from it a bit, they'll also help reduce the
pressure on the rest of us. And if they fail
to cut their consumption or curb their consumption
for their own self-interests, we'll all suffer
as a result.
HAASS: Last question for me then I'll open
it up.
Do you get the sense with the new leadership
in China there is any reconsideration of this
policy, given some of the things you've just
alluded to? Are there people now really saying
are we sure we want to be doing this as much
as we've been doing it, and much in the same
way as we've been doing it? Is any of this
being, if you will, revisited in a serious
fashion?
ECONOMY: I think with -- I haven't seen anything
with just this new leadership. I think that
there's been an effort, you know within the
ministry of commerce, within some of the bureaucracies
to start over the past few years beginning
to develop better policies for companies you
know saying you must undertake an environmental
impact assessment or you're not going to get
a loan.
I think that kind of thing has been taking
place. Or you know stock exchanges trying
to say you know you must report to us if you've
been blacklisted by the Environmental Protection
Agency.
I think at that level you do see some things.
I think the foreign ministry's extremely concerned.
I met with the No. 2 of both the Africa and
the Latin America departments, and they both
said they're spending an enormous amount of
time setting up like mini consulates out in
some of these mining areas to deal with all
of the problems that these resource investments
are causing for the Chinese image.
So I think that there's consideration at that
level. But I haven't really seen a serious
rethink yet emanating from the top about the
overall approach to doing investment.
LEVI: So one place where there's some learning
I think is, at least in some parts of the
Chinese government there's increasing appreciation
that owning the resources overseas doesn't
necessarily give you a lot of additional security.
I think there was a very strong belief in
that direction 10, 15 years ago. There's more
trust of the market, though it's not complete
yet.
That said, because they institutionalized
a lot of the incentives that grew out of that
fear of the mark and the desire to control
resources, the shift in opinions doesn't necessarily
translate to a shift in how the government
operates.
I think the other place where they probably
leaned in more or are increasingly leaning
in more is in the military side. I think this
new leadership, Liz can talk about this more
than I can, but has really focused on the
military. And that's inevitably going to lead
to more discussion about China providing its
own security for the sea lanes over which
its resources travel.
HAASS: Well, we're not seeing that yet in
the Middle East or Persian Gulf, but I'm curious
to see it.
LEVI: Closer to home.
HAASS: One last question. Sorry. Which is,
did you ever come across anyone in the Chinese
government who had studied the American or
Japanese experience and said we're going to
learn from this and do it differently?
ECONOMY: No.
HAASS: OK. Just curious.
HAASS: OK. A perfect place to open up -- no
more trick questions.
(LAUGHTER)
ECONOMY: I think...
HAASS: Sure? If people would just introduce
themselves, wait for a microphone. We'll get
as many...
QUESTION: Thank you.
HAASS: ... questions as we can.
QUESTION: Mahesh Kotacha (ph). Thank you very
much, Elizabeth and your coauthor. Thank you
for the great introduction to the book.
My question, Elizabeth, is to you on the issue
of the institutional arrangements with respect
to infrastructure which the Chinese embed
or try to embed in the countries in which
they invest into infrastructure. It is said
that there is not as much stress on the rule
of law and on institutional arrangements for
markets to work to allow prices to work for
the infrastructure created if it's public-private
type partnerships.
Could you comment on is that what you meant?
And are they then doing what Richard asked
about learning from U.S. experience or Western
experience on insisting on rule of law, proper
contracts and the like in order to invest?
I hear of some kind of efforts on the part
of the Development Bank of China, China Development
Bank, and the others to try to learn from
this experience and co-invest in fact?
ECONOMY: In terms of the infrastructure I
haven't seen much learning taking place. I'm
trying to think of any cases. Mike I think
probably has looked at the oil and gas sector
and seen a fair amount of co-investing. But
in terms of -- I haven't seen -- I have to
say I haven't seen the rule of law become
a particularly important element in the infrastructure
sector when China's gone abroad to these particular
countries. I haven't seen them pushing that
issue.
I think we found more for it to be the case
that states with stronger capacity would push
the Chinese to do a better job.
LEVI: And then in oil and gas the Chines often
co-invest out of necessity. They don't have
the technological capability or the managerial
capability to develop a lot of the big resources
that are out there.
But I don't think you see an inclination where
they don't have to work with others to go
out of their way to do it.
HAASS: There's one on this side. Sure?
QUESTION: Greg Lindsay with the World Policy
Institute. I was just curious if you came
across in your reporting sort of instances
of interesting sort of economic blowback in
terms of how China is transforming economies
in the sense of where they're locating headquarters,
locating units, and also how they're using
Africa as a bridgehead to export into it.
So for example I think one of the things that's
underreported about Dubai is that something
like 2,000 Chinese companies have set up headquarters
there. There's 150,000 Chinese in Dubai because
they use it as their North African headquarters,
and because they're exporting so much into
Africa.
Considering there's a whole narrative around
the U.S., that we're going to export our way
into emerging markets as a way to bring back
the American economy, have the Chinese beaten
us to it in Africa because of that?
ECONOMY: I think one of the complaints within
Africa is in fact that the Chinese are extracting
the resources and then exporting finished
products. And one of the things that the Chinese
have tried to do not only in Africa, but largely
in Africa, is to develop these export zones,
somewhat modeled on some of the Chinese -- its
own economic development history and trajectory.
They have not -- although there's a debate
over how effective or successful they've been
I would say that the weight of evidence is
that they are not particularly successful.
And you know the idea is to set up manufacturing
zones basically in these countries in order
to encourage sort of the kinds of skills and
training and development that the African
countries and others are asking of the Chinese
so that they're not just those neocolonialists.
And so far I would say we have not heard a
lot of positive reporting about the -- about
what's been developed. I think maybe there's
one case, Mauritius maybe. But by and large
you find things like first of all, companies
don't want to participate in them.
Or for example the -- you know 17 Chinese
companies will be there, but they're all sort
of subsidiaries of the Chinese construction
companies and they're just really feeding
into that process and nothing really is developing
that's going to assist in the development
of the local population.
So, I think that is the Chinese effort. But
I don't think it's really developed in a way
that's made much of a difference.
LEVI: Your point about inward exports into
these countries is interesting. A lot of these
places when you go to them and you try to
get people to talk to you about what they
like and they don't like about Chinese activities
and resources, all they want to talk to you
about is the cheap Chinese goods of the market
that are putting their people out of work.
And so it's really important when you look
country by country and try to understand the
impact of this resource quest that you make
sure that the things that you're seeing happening
are actually a result of that effort to secure
resources. A lot of the times they're about
these other things, like you point out, that
are tenuously connected to what's happening
in resources, but really a different phenomenon.
HAASS: Bob Hormetz (ph)? You need a microphone,
sir.
QUESTION: Thanks very much. I have a question.
But I just wanted to make one comment on from
whom the Chinese have learned. The one thing,
if they've learned anything from anyone about
this, is the European experience, which is,
don't become too dependent on any one supplier.
I think that's really one of the interesting
things. They saw how the Europeans became
very heavily dependent on particularly Gazprom.
And they have made a major effort to diversify
their sourcing, which is rather interesting.
The point I'm particularly interested in asking
you to pursue a little bit further, there
are a lot of negatives to the Chinese and
their sort of gold rush to get mines and steel
and all these other things. But you could
make -- and we've had a lot of issues with
them.
The one point you could make, though, on the
other side is to the extent their production
is additive that they go into countries that
no one else would go into either because their
social policies are so abhorrent, their politics
are so awful, Sudan and others. Or they simply
are willing to take these risks that Liz talked
about, which is plunk money down and then
hope they can get results down the road.
How do you weigh that, because that really
is an interesting positive-negative yin-yang
for the markets there?
ECONOMY: And I'm the negative and Mike's the
positive. So I'm going to let Mike talk about
this.
QUESTION: There's obviously a debate and there's
no real answer...
LEVI: Yes.
ECONOMY: Yes.
QUESTION: ... but it's an interesting debate.
ECONOMY: Right. Yes.
LEVI: So let me make a very quick observation
on your Gazprom, lesson learned point, which
is really important. The Chinese have discovered
an alternative to imported natural gas. Unfortunately
it's coal. It's domestic coal. And it has
-- it creates big problems for them domestically
and for us internationally.
But that's one of those places where I'm skeptical
that you'll see enormous Chinese demand for
importing natural gas and develop -- unless
they can find ways to continually diversify.
If they can't they'll just choose to use a
different fuel source.
QUESTION: Or develop their own.
LEVI: Or develop their own if they can.
So, on this question of additive versus something
else, yes. I think particularly when the Chinese
are willing to take risks that others aren't,
that when they are very patient, they don't
need to report to their investors for the
next quarter, they can have -- they can add
to the global supply of oil in particular.
So a market that's genuinely global, benefiting
consumers everywhere.
I think you have to be a bit careful though.
Again, you can have a bit of a sugar high
from some of these things with dangerous long-term
consequences. If China's investing in places
and creating the image of a lot of supply,
that can deter investment in supply elsewhere.
And so if the Chinese supply ultimately doesn't
materialize or if it's volatile because of
bad security situations, then you can end
up worse off than when you started. So it's
a complicated mix. But certainly that force
is there and you have to think about it when
you're doing a net assessment of what's happening.
HAASS: Sure?
QUESTION: Richard Greco from Filangieri Capital
Partners.
One resource that we can't live without is
water. And my understanding is that China
has a real shortage and a problem with clean
water for environmental reasons just because
of a lack of water sources to begin with.
What's China doing to secure its clean water
sources? Is it succeeding? And if not, what
are the consequences?
LEVI: Someone should write a book about that
subject.
ECONOMY: I know, The River Runs Black.
OK. So, yes, the water issue. I mean China
is -- primarily China is doing things on the
home front, right. So whether it's pushing
forward on desalinization or experimenting
with water pricing, they have a lot of the
sort of traditional tools at their disposal
that other countries use as well that are
water short, conservation, you know pushing
forward with a lot of different kinds of experiments.
In terms of our book, we looked at China's
control of the headwaters of some of Asia's
most important rivers. And in two cases in
particular we look at the Mekong, we look
at the Ili, which goes up into Kazakhstan,
and we looked at the Yarlung Zangbo, which
becomes the Brahmaputra.
And the Mekong is a different issue because
it's an energy related one primarily, hydropower
plants. But in both the case of India and
Kazakhstan, there's talk of river diversion,
right, to help China. And that is actually
something that China does a lot of internally,
its own river diversions, enormous river diversions.
And so what we found, and this was a case
where I think the hype surrounding it turned
out to be greater in the reality. You know
in the case of Kazakhstan the Kazakhs have
pushed the Chinese. They're worried that the
Chinese have talked about diverting, in several
places diverting water.
And the Kazakhs are worried. And they've gotten
the Chinese to the point of talking about
you know water quality and sort of preliminarily
talking about resource allocation, but no
formal agreement.
The Chinese are extremely reluctant to acknowledge
that there are shared water rights in that
respect. In no case do they recognize that,
and they haven't signed onto the U.N. agreement
that recognizes that. They're one of only
three countries in the world in fact. And
so they -- the Kazakhs have made more progress
in many respects than anybody else that we
looked at.
In the Indian case certainly there's going
to be damning, more damning of the Yarlung
Zangbo. But it does not look as though there's
going to be the river diversion aspect of
it that has received enormous amount of tension
India.
And some of you may have read Brahma Chellaney's
book on this topic and he's quite concerned.
He's probably the most vociferous and agitated
person, you know expert scholar out there.
But for reasons of actual technical feasibility
it doesn't seem possible.
The Chinese have denied that they have any
such plans on the books. That to me is not
sufficient proof because lots of times the
Chinese deny things and then quietly start
doing them. But in this case it seems that
technically it's not even feasible.
HAASS: Michael Pillsbury (ph)?
QUESTION: Thank you. I wanted to present you
with a puzzle that I cannot solve. But it
picks up on both something Michael said about
not trusting the market that they trust the
market more now but it was a pretty low level
of trust 20 years ago, and something Elizabeth
started out with about orders from on high,
the National Development Commission and others.
And we just had about 216 military delegations
come in the Pentagon. I had not been there
for all 216, but I've been there for most
of them. They often bring up resources and
they're being slandered for raping Africa
and this kind of thing. They think we do that,
which we don't.
But the puzzle is when I've asked them for
books, theories, who back in Beijing is advising
your leaders about the quest for resources
and all means necessary? Where is this coming
from? And I thought there'd be no books. Instead
they gave me 20 books over time.
They've got a formula, this comprehensive
national power formula which everything's
weighted. Military force is only 10 percent,
resources is much more. They've got complicated
lists of rich resources to get. As you say,
it's sort of like assignments to the companies
so that economists know this is stupid. It's
inefficient. You waste money.
But if -- does it make sense to you? This
is the puzzle. Does it make sense to you that
their system is still top-down driven enough
that the petroleum university and the people
who do the CNP scoring are somehow influencing
decisionmakers at the Politbureau level. It's
driving what Richard asked you, the title
of your book. Go out and do this.
And when the economists object, Chinese economists,
this is stupid, it's costing us 30 percent
or 40 percent more than it should, the decision
makers are so certain that we live in a resource,
almost paranoid resource conflict world, almost
a paranoid view, that these orders must be
obeyed. And that's what your book essentially
is showing is that the behavior that follows
from these top-down formulas that are actually
in their reading materials.
Sorry for the long question, but I wanted
to get the puzzle out to you that I claim
I can't solve.
ECONOMY: Do you want to start and then I'll
go?
LEVI: Sure.
So, if you're a high-level policymaker, you're
usually not optimizing, you're trying to manage
risk. And so even if you start to believe
in the market, if you're not totally there
it might make sense for you to follow some
of this and to still try and encourage your
companies to invest and to secure resources
in these different ways.
I think it's only when you start to see some
of the strong countervailing risks on the
other side, the down sides of doing these
things wrong that you really revisit some
of that. And so you don't need to only look
to China to see this sort of sense of risk
aversion among policymakers when it comes
to this. There are plenty of economists in
the United States who will tell policymakers
that it doesn't matter whether it's a U.S.
company producing oil abroad or a foreign
company.
It matters for commercial success and it's
important for American businesses to see it.
But it doesn't matter for security of oil
supply. But over and over our State Department
can be persuaded, to different degrees at
different times in our history, but can be
persuaded to go out and help make sure American
companies succeed in investing in oil, in
part through an energy security argument.
So this is a powerful argument. And it turns
out that even hundreds of economists often
are unsuccessful in persuading policymakers
to change their tactic.
ECONOMY: Let me just make one...
HAASS: Quickly.
ECONOMY: ... small addition.
HAASS: We got (inaudible) more questions in.
ECONOMY: OK. So I think one thing that you
certainly appreciate, Mike, is that this has
a long history within China itself, right.
And so the idea that the state will direct
the resource quest and will determine even
within China what resources should be developed
or not developed is -- dates back to the Ming,
right, when they would say we're not going
to grow tobacco, we're going to grow rice,
right, or we're going to grow grain because
tobacco is a waste for us. So I think that
there are long roots to sort of the state-directed
development and quest for resources and control
over who profits and who participates.
I also think that the story is probably a
little more complicated than the military
side is making out because I certainly spoke
to people in the Chinese Academy of Social
Sciences who talked about how they were pushing
their leaders to be more concerned with resources,
right, especially when it comes to Southeast
Asia and places like the Philippines and cobalt,
for example. Please take a more -- take a
more positive approach to the Philippines
or Vietnam than you're taking because we need
those resources because we get a lot of resources
from those countries and you're endangering
that.
So I think that the -- a lot of different
interest groups playing into this at this
point.
HAASS: Sergio Galvez (ph).
QUESTION: Thank you. This goes a little bit
to one of Richard's questions about effects
within China and within Chinese dynamics.
A stereotypical view of state-owned enterprises
is that somebody is sitting there deciding
who pursues what opportunities. And that stereotype
might be right, might not be right, may have
been right at some point, may not be right
today. But there is anecdotal evidence that
there's actually an enormous game going on
internally on the pursuit of opportunities
and competition for the opportunity to pursue
opportunities.
Can you let us know sort of were you able
to get into that some? And what did you find?
ECONOMY: Do you want to talk about...
LEVI: So I mean -- I'm not recalling a specific
instance right here. But there are cases where
multiple Chinese companies bid against each
other for overseas resources. That doesn't
sound like a purely state-directed initiative.
And the reality is these guys are running
big businesses and a lot of this is commercially
driven. Again, the state creates a framework
within which being commercially successful
and commercially driven is going to also in
a lot of cases deliver on national goals.
But that's different from this being all orchestrated
from the top.
So I think you see that competition. I'm sure
you also see competition politically. Again,
my guess is that the heads of various oil
companies would all love to be the energy
minister. Only one of them can be. And it
might be someone else.
So there's competition to be -- to have a
successful company, to be able to invest,
but also political competition.
HAASS: OK. We've got time for -- yes, sir?
Make that the last one. I apologize for the
several of you we weren't able to get to.
We'll blame it on the authors for the length
of their answers.
QUESTION: Thank you. Dick Huber from Invina
Wine Group.
We export a lot of agricultural products to
China, I mean wine and blueberries and such
things from Chile and soybeans from Brazil.
And we've always expected to see greater investment
in agriculture in -- abroad. And we haven't
seen it.
They -- we love them dearly. They buy. They
tend to pay on time and all those good things.
But we -- and we'd love to sell them a couple
of vineyards, I mean...
(LAUGHTER)
But there's been very, very little investment
in agriculture production, and certainly in
the three countries I'm involved with, which
are Brazil, Argentina and Chile. You see -- is
that a barrier? Or is that something just
that will come later? How do you see that?
Thank you.
ECONOMY: So I would guess that the wine is
coming. And in fact in the Chinese media there
was an article just maybe a week ago talking
about the growing interests of Chinese agricultural
sector in the United States in particular.
But when I -- I did some work in Brazil for
the book. And when I was there, again thinking
back to the, you know $70 billion of planned
investment, you know what I heard from Brazilian
officials was the Chinese delegations would
come one after another to talk about investment.
But what would happen, a couple of things.
First, the Chinese expected that the Brazilian
officials could simply you know sign a piece
of paper and transfer the land to them. That's
not how our land system works here. That may
be what happens in China, right, officials
and you know business people can collude and
expropriate land, but that's not how we do
it here. So that was one problem.
The second one was they said a lot of the
times these Chinese delegations really didn't
seem that serious about investing. That Brazil
is a nice place to visit.
All of these you know officials and local
governments have money for foreign trade delegations.
And so they simply come over, you know spend
a day doing business and then head off to
Rio and have a good time. So they felt that
there wasn't a lot of seriousness.
But I do think from talking to the Chinese
side that part of the problem in Brazil in
particular is a lack of infrastructure as
well. And so there's -- you know and the Chinese
have tried to give -- and the Brazilians have
tried to give the Chinese interest in that
part of it and have not been as successful.
And finally I'll say the Brazilians themselves
were quite worried about potential flood of
Chinese investment into the agricultural sector
and buying Brazilian land. And so in 2010
they revised their laws, bringing parts of
the old law back that made it much more difficult
to own land. We could only do a minority stake
in a joint venture. So in that particular
case that was a big part of the problem as
well.
HAASS: Let's just say two things.
This book on the back flap it says "This is
a Council on Foreign Relations book." And
it's one of the things we do because books
are an important part of our culture and our
mission here. And we encourage our fellows,
indeed we expect our fellows to essentially
make books. It's not the entire part of their
portfolio, but it's a central part because
in the process of writing a book you've got
to do a depth and breadth of research that
informs the rest of your work.
This is but the latest of a book-oriented
culture that we, again, encourage and require
here. And it's part of our larger commitment
to doing serious policy-relevant scholarship,
and that's just what this is. This is policy-relevant
scholarship because it deals with this important
aspect now of China's emergence on the world
stage. And it has consequences for China and
all the places they're emerging into.
You have an opportunity to buy the book as
you leave. You will then have an opportunity
to read the book. But again, the sequence
is important. And at any point in that sequence
you also have the opportunity to have some
more to eat, to have something to drink, to
privately ask Liz and Michael some questions,
but most immediately to congratulate them
on the book they have just published.
(APPLAUSE)
ECONOMY: Thanks, Richard. Thank you.